i can't believe we're at hogwarts no
that's
buckingham palace hogwarts is fictional
do you know that it's important to me
that you know that
okay guys we are going to be sightseeing
today andy and ben are gonna go to their
meeting and then we're gonna go back to
the hotel for lunch
and i will spend the day getting to know
london's history
history began on july 4th 1776.
everything before that was a mistake
diane suggested we tag along to london
for a honeymoon i agreed because my love
for her
trumps my hatred for europe then she hit
a phase of morning sickness that knocked
her for a loop and decided to stay
home but she insisted i go and take
pictures for her all of this could have
been avoided if we'd followed my plan
for a honeymoon
a steak dinner a glass of lagavulin
whiskey then vigorous lovemaking for two
hours
and we're both asleep by 8 30. the
notting hill bus tour starts at two
the love actually bus tour starts at 2
30 and oh the bridget jones bus tour
starts at 2 30 also
what do we do ron your pick
look a clock we don't have that in
america
you call that a tower try the sears
tower friend
london at night that is very funny
can i help you sir yes i will take this
uh we don't accept american currency sir
of course you do that's the most
wonderful piece of paper in the world
accept it very so he said fine
enjoy the fact that your royal overlords
are a frail old woman and a tiny baby
[Music]
where the hell are you sending me nope
all my life i have avoided europe and
its multitudes of terribleness
but it turns out much to my surprise
there is actually one place in europe
that is worth seeing
[Music]
these tiny islands off the coast of
scotland where god's chosen elixirs are
distilled
barreled and prepared for consumption
this
is worth the trip
dear ron you have now reached the
cliffsides overlooking the islands
as you sit here and gaze upon the waters
please read out loud the poem by the
great scotsman robert
burns love leslie
a worm i love yon lilac fair
with purple blossoms to the spring and i
a bird
to shelter there when wearied on my
little wing
how i would mourn when it was torn
by autumn wild and winter rude
but i would sing on wanton wing
when youthful may it's bloom renewed
[Music]
i don't know what she thought i'd get
out of that
you